I think it's rather a tall order to be
able to figure out how you can spread
this everywhere but if you see that
majority of the population a lot is in
rural areas and a lot of as urban areas
sometimes the best way I think is of
improving the education as has already
been discussed earlier and the most
important is also very likely as
providing finances and the use of the
Indian government services like the
postal services to be able to read the
bankers as well for this and then as was
recently discussed just now this last
session the first session the use of
maybe private sector in education from
the part together with the public sector
to improve our standard of education and
also the same thing would go with health
care then after that you can start
providing the jobs